[Musica]
il futuro quando mi chiedono come
funziona il futuro cos'è il futuro parla
del futuro Io in realtà non ho capito
bene come funziona il futuro Cioè nel
senso che non so dove arriva quando
arriva come funziona Se arriva
all'improvviso qui ho cercato una
definizione di futuro il futuro
Sostanzialmente è il tempo dopo il
presente
facile in realtà quando avevo 20 anni il
futuro non esisteva perché a vent'anni
era talmente lontano e c'era mio nonno
urlando che mi diceva Oh ma non ti
preoccupare che il tempo vola
io guardavo Boh Eccomi qua 49 anni 20
anni passati così 30 quasi bruciate sono
qua davanti a voi Così un secondo
questi quasi 30 anni lo dico così mi
preparo ai 50 anni sono successe
veramente un sacco di robe e la domanda
era sempre la stessa in questi 30 anni
Quale sarà la cosa che io non capirò
perché adesso per esempio visti tutti i
trascorsi tutto il casino che è successo
in questi anni arriveranno gli alieni
probabilmente no Oppure ci sono altri
trasporto Però magari io capirò il
teletrasporto la tecnologia Ma di sicuro
non mi farò incenerire e ricomporre da
un'altra parte prenderò l'aereo
probabilmente no però comunque queste
cose le capirò
invece tanti anni fa ho comprato un
cellulare a mio nonno gliel'ho messo in
mano e gli ho detto guarda nonno Adesso
ti faccio vedere come possiamo chattare
se tu scrivi questi messaggini Quindi
lui ci mette 10 minuti scrive i
messaggini lui aveva un sacco di anni
scrive messaggini invio e due secondi
dopo sul mio cellulare a fare lo stesso
messaggino quindi la super orgoglioso mi
giro verso mia nonna e gli dico guarda
un po' lui mi guarda mi fa
effettivamente funziona e perché non ti
posso telefonare ho il telefono in mano
effettivamente non ho avuto il coraggio
di rispondergli Però lui in realtà non
l'aveva capito internet perché quello lì
era internet lui no non guardavo dalla
parte giusta non l'aveva non l'aveva
colto oggi Quanti di voi telefono e
quanti di voi mandano messaggi Diciamo
che impari la cosa no
perché in questi anni sono successe
veramente tantissime cose tra cui per
esempio la pandemia so se vi siete
accorti che nel 2020 si stava la
pandemia no
E chi è che di voi ha fatto una riunione
con il proprio capo il proprio team e
magari non era fisicamente presente l'ha
fatta con zoom o con qualsiasi software
di videoconferenza state la mano
figata
e non eravate nella sala eravate magari
chi di questi era a fare la spesa non lo
vedo oppure col Bancomat con la giacca
senza pantaloni sotto robe del genere
gli altri stanno mentendo
E chi di voi è stato licenziato per
questa cosa
nessuno perché in realtà Se voi aveste
fatto questa stessa cosa nel 2019 solo
un anno prima Probabilmente licenziavano
perché se voi vi presentavate dal capo
di Giovanni Scusa sta facendo la spesa
posso mi collego però eh licenziato vai
in ufficio in giacca e cravatta in
mutande licenziato Nel 2020 invece
normale quindi siamo passati in un anno
online direttamente subito oggi è
normale fare videoconferenze video
collant spesso si fanno e spesso magari
qualcuno non abita più in centro ma
abitava qualche altra parte perché si
connette il remoto no
l'altra cosa che è successa è che tutti
parlano di questo
E com'è che si entra nel metaverso
C'è un'app sito
Chi è che nel metaverso di voi
perfetto
chissà cos'è il metaverso
Allora vedete qui per favore
Ora provo a farvi un altro esempio
questo ero io tondo esattamente così a
13 anni Quindi il mio la mia vita era
quella lì e tutti i miei amici erano nel
raggio 10 km Io prendevo la mia
bicicletta andava al bar andavo nella
piazzetta andava da qualche parte
incontrava i miei amici alle 2:30 di
pomeriggio parlavamo delle morosette e
le avventure del dei compiti da copiare
del giorno dopo che si arrivava sempre
sulle cose insomma Sarà capitato a tutti
quanti voi No io adesso però
incredibilmente in questi 30 anni ho
fatto anche due figli chiede di voi ha
dei figli
O che almeno sa di avere dei figli
ok
il raggio di amici dei vostri figli non
è più questo il raggio di amici degli
amici e i vostri figli è questo perché
probabilmente loro adesso proprio in
questo momento stanno chattando con
qualcuno che non è nel raggio di 10 km
loro Probabilmente stanno parlando con
qualcuno che è ben al di là dei 10 km e
un'altra cosa ennesima che è successa in
questi anni sono l'avvento di un sacco
di giochi tipo Roblox fortnite Minecraft
che ha genitore sa benissimo le madonne
che ha preso guardando Minecraft i
ragazzini appiccicati al monitor stanno
lì no per favore non ci stare le ore bla
bla vero
se tu hai avuto coraggio Grazie solo i
miei e i suoi i vostri
in realtà se li Guardate bene però loro
indossano le cuffie e non solo stanno
giocando ma stanno parlando con gli
altri amici Nel senso che loro sono non
so se conoscete Minecraft c'è questa
tempesta che si chiude e devi star
dentro e uccidere tutti è l'ultimo che
rimane vince No in realtà loro li stanno
facendo lì dentro è parlare con loro
amici chattare chiacchierare fare
passarsi i compiti il tema è che noi che
non concepiamo perché non esci Perché
non vai con loro perché stai attaccato a
Queste cuffie ora per darvi Un'idea dei
numeri di fortnite per esempio uno dei
giorni ma gli altri sono più o meno
uguali nei primi due anni hanno fatto
160 milioni di utenti 20 utenti 20
milioni di utenti collegati
contemporaneamente a giocare e un
fatturato di 9 miliardi di dollari
che per un gioco gratuito
Secondo me è una bufala
il tema però è che per esempio questo
maglione che io sto indossando adesso
che non dovrei farlo perché sono alte di
x e la mia voce mi ucciderà ma ho anche
un buco sotto il maglione questo
maglione costa 10 euro più o meno No se
io prendessi lo stesso maglione magari
con una firma qui sopra potrebbe costare
molto più di 10 euro ok Il tema che se
tornassi indietro di 400 anni
potesse di fronte a un contadino dicessi
Guarda questo maglione costa 10 euro
quest'altro uguale identico proprio
preciso spaccato ha solo un'etichetta
Rossa qui sopra gialla con un omino
costa 600 euro
Il contadino Niguarda praticamente
dovrebbe essere un deficiente è ovvio
che devi comprare la 10 euro non puoi
comprare quello della Challenge che cosa
stai facendo e invece tutti quanti noi
abbiamo comprato un vestito da €1000 un
orologio a €2000 perché noi siamo molto
fisici Noi abbiamo bisogno noi
giudichiamo in base a questa cosa
infatti questo cosa ci ha di strano per
esempio cos'è che ho notato di questo
dottore
che non ha i capelli non è una cosa
niente Infatti questo il dottore
normalissimo e tutti noi ci faremo
visitare questo dottore se non fosse del
pannello incontriamo nel weekend
in realtà voi avete riso Ma lui è sempre
la stessa persona magari ha vinto il
premio Nobel è bravissimo e tutto quanto
perché noi la nostra generazione è
fisica è abituata a giudicare in base a
quello che vedete Se io fossi salito in
giacca e cravatta o vestito con un buco
sul maglione voi avete un giudizio di me
piuttosto che un altro se io quando
vengo a cena con voi e verrò a cena con
voi con tutti quanti appoggio sul tavolo
l'iPhone di ultimissima generazione o il
Nokia del 1990 voi immediatamente mi
giudicate in un modo piuttosto che un
altro perché la nostra la nostra
generazione fisica la loro generazione
quella successiva non è fisica perché
loro stanno facendo esattamente le
stesse cose che facciamo noi Loro si
trovano in piazza a chiedere i compiti
copiati Ma la nostra Piazza era il
raggio di 10 km la loro Piazza invece è
online nel suo fortnite su Minecraft da
qualche altra parte se voi mi trovate
non affascinante il discorso che sta
facendo voi siete fisici e siete
obbligati a stare lì e ascoltarmi magari
fate la battuta con quello che avete a
fianco a voi se lo fate con le nuove
generazioni Non sono obbligate ad
ascoltarmi loro prendono il telefono e
chattano per una persona che ritengono
più interessante di quella che stanno
guardando davanti a noi che può essere
in quel momento dall'altra parte del
mondo per cui loro hanno bypassato la
cosa del Oddio dobbiamo essere fisici
dobbiamo stare qua davanti per noi
invece questa cosa è molto molto fisica
Infatti il futuro come ce la immaginiamo
noi e quello fatto con gli occhiali tipo
questi no che tu indossi gli occhiali
come memoria ti report tipo questi e ti
vedi tutte le cosine davanti Sai quelle
cose tipo nei film no questi occhiali in
realtà hanno già le cuffie attive per
cui se io parlano il microfono posso
rispondere al telefono posso fare così e
adesso sto condividendo su Instagram e
su Facebook tutta questa cosa fighissima
tutto quanto bellissimo Ecco chi è che
di voi comprerebbe questa cosa per
mandare i vostri video su Instagram
Perfetto Io bene
Io pensavo che alzasse tutti la mano
Vabbè in realtà a Google hanno fatto un
esperimento visto che Questi occhiali
hanno un microfono e hanno delle stecche
che fanno sentire l'audio
tu mi parli in cinese e gli occhiali mi
rispondono in italiano quindi mentre tu
mi parli Io ascolto in italiano quello
che tu mi stai dicendo in cinese cerca
di comprare il bene adesso
quelli che l'hanno alzato le mani o solo
di Google o hanno mentito Ok In realtà
siamo passati da un minuto all'altro ma
una cosa completamente inutile se un
deficiente e spesso i soldi a tutti mi
chiederanno dopo Dov'è che si pompano
esattamente perché quella cosa di Google
come hai fatto
perché in realtà quello che succede che
mio nonno mi ha detto oltre a questa
cosa qua era tipo amante devi
preoccuparti del futuro perché tanto non
ci puoi far niente Lui era di Roma no
farai quello che ti piace fare e poi
dopo vedrai che le cose funzionano Cioè
più o meno la stessa cosa che ha detto
Steve Jobs un botto di anni dopo a
Stanford in inglese molto più figo no
per cui la brutta notizia è che noi
siamo quel contadino di 400 anni fa che
noi non capiamo certe cose che non
vediamo eccetera eccetera la bella
notizia è che stiamo cercando il futuro
della parte sbagliata perché il futuro
non è davanti a noi basta girarci
guardare il casino di puntini che
abbiamo combinato la nostra vita
scegliere i migliori
e unirli ed è in quel momento esatto che
arriva al futuro
per cui il futuro non arriva
all'improvviso basta unire puntini che
avete già seminato Grazie
[Applauso]